اعلن المدعي العام السويدي ماتش ليون فيست
قائده فريق التحقيقات العثور على اثار
مواد متفجره بالقرب من خطي انابيب نور
ستريم واحد واثنان ما يؤكد تعرض الخطين
لعمل تخريبي
قال انه خلال التحقيقات في مسرح الجريمه
في بحر البلطيق اظهرت اثاره متفجرات على
العديد من الاجسام الغريبه او ظهرت على
العديد من الاجسام الغريبه التي تم العثور
عليها ووصف المدعي العام السويدي التحقيق
بانه معقد للغايه وشامل لافتا الى انه
نتائج التحقيقات المستمره ستؤكد امكانيه
تقديم اي شخص للاشتباه في ارتكاب جريمه
وكان تفجير قد الحق اضرارا بخطين واحد
واثنين في بحر البطيق وتبادل روسيا والدول
الغربيه الاتهامات بشان المسؤوليه عن
التفجير
ينضم الينا من ستوكهولم السيد ديمتريوس
كركمانس الباحث السابق في معهد الدفاع
الوطني السويدي سيدمتريوس هل من الممكن
معرفه الجاني من المواد المتفجره
لهم لا يشيرون الى اي شخص الى اي مرتكب
فقط بيان صحفي وهو مستمر
هل من الممكن معرفه الجهه التي تقف خلف
التفجير من المواد المتفجره التي تم
العثور عليها
النووي التيشنات قاسي
[موسيقى]
وبحاسب المدعي ما يزال هناك تحقيق
ويحتاجون المزيد من الوقت
لكي يكون هناك
استنتاجات وهم الان لا يشرون الى اي شخص
لازالت مستمره ولكن ما تم الكشف عنه حتى
الان انه هناك مواد متفجره وبالتالي هناك
عمل تخريبي ما الذي يعني
اكشن
طيور
في عين المكان تم القيام بها في بحر
البلطيق
وتم
العثور على عينات
وهم
يدرسونها
ويحللونها والتحليلات التي
تم تدور الى ان هناك
اثار لمتفجرات
لكن
السورتات السويديه تتعاون مع الدنماركين
والالمان
[موسيقى]
وهم يعملون
بشكل مكثف
ولكن
المدعي يطلب باستمرار العمل لانه من المهم
ان يستمر في العمل دون ازعاج والهم هو انه
ما يزال ومبكرا
للقول بانه يمكن توجيه تهمه الى جهه معينه
وبصبيعه الحال هذه التصريحات
يلا ماشي
عناصر خارجيه وجدوها في عين المكان طيب
امام هذه المعطيات التي لدينا الان ما
الذي يبحث عنه المحققون لتحديد هويه
المسؤول عن عن هذا الحادث يعني ما هي
العناصر التي ستمكن المحققين من التنقل من
هويه من يقف خلف هذا هذا التفجير
هي
الاشياء التي يمكنهم ان يجدوها في عين
المكان
والتحليل لكنهم لا يقولون اكثر من ذلك
لديهم مواد كثيره وهم يقومون بتحليلها
ويعتقدون انه في الوقت المناسب سوف يكونون
قادرين على ان يرسموا معالم سوره اوضح
شكرا دي متريوس كركمانوس الباحث السابق في
معهد الدفاع الوطني السوري